est une ville bien triste dans cette fin
avril il fait froid il pleut son
centre-ville et désert c'est à peine si
l'on voit la baie de casco magnifique
paysage qu'offre la petite ville de
Maine une ville où la pêche est au cœur
des traditions tout comme l'accueil des
immigrants
Pedro est originaire d'Angola il a
demandé l'anonymat pour ne pas nuire à
sa demande d'asile quand j'ai quitté mon
pays j'ai quitté pour aller demander
l'asile au Canada militant politique
dans son pays il a fui en catastrophe
le gouvernement il laisse derrière lui
sa femme et sa fille
[Musique]
depuis janvier plus de 1000 demandeurs
d'asile provenant principalement
d'Afrique ont afflué à Portland et leur
nombre ne cesse d'augmenter
c'est que l'État du Maine a un programme
d'aide sociale parmi les plus généreux
[Musique]
la ville les héberge dans des centres
temporaires ce centre sportif a même été
réquisitionné en urgence tout est déjà
plein les migrants doivent quitter les
lieux pour la plupart des sept heures
chaque jour pour
errer à la recherche de repères qu'il
trouve chez Lucie une congolaise venue
s'établir il y a 10 ans dans son
épicerie elle propose des produits de
partout en Afrique pour quelques dollars
donnés par la ville les migrants
retrouvent les arômes de leur pays mais
surtout le sourire de Lucie réconfortant
les rues froides de Portland engourdi
transit il cherche refuge dans la
bibliothèque au YMCA il tue le temps
[Musique]
le soir venu Jean retrouve ses
compagnons de fortune dans le chaos de
Lord dortoir nous sommes arrivés ici
ça se passe encore très mal
je manque même le mot pour dire comment
qu'on se passe-t-il
c'est ici que Jean et sa famille mangent
on nettoie grossièrement on installe des
matelas pour la nuit un vacarme
difficile à soutenir sans accès aux
douches ils sont plus de 70 à dormir ici
comme Albert moi je suis sur beaucoup
ici je suis ici depuis 5 mois
avec ma femme
je suis soufflé mon plan ils arrivent
pour la plupart de l'Angola et du Congo
une fois l'océan traversé un périple
impitoyable commence partant du Brésil
parfois en bus le plus souvent à pied
Jacqueline croyait qu'une fois la jungle
les rivières les frontières traversées
sont cauchemar serait terminé
ici pour sauver ma vie ditel mais il
n'en est rien
le désespoir frappe je suis perdu je
suis perdu
et la fermeture du chemin Roxane le 25
mars dernier n'a fait qu'amplifier leur
détresse
Pedro se sont aspirés dans un trou noir
mais il ne veut pas se laisser sombrer
j'ai peur des familles avec ma fille il
faut que je donne l'avenir
faut que je travaille je donne ce que je
peux faire pour ma fille il espère
toujours venir au Canada peuvent changer
l'idée et donner l'action aux immigrants
pour traverser la frontière s'ils
peuvent penser
à l'humanité de nous donner encore
l'accès d'aller vivre chez eux
autrement il craint le grand naufrage
[Rires]